[Applauso]
[Musica]
impresa e società per me sono fatte una
per l'altra
l'impresa nasce per servire la società e
la società la società moderna ha estremo
bisogno dell'impresa purtroppo per via
dei tanti esempi negativi che abbiamo
sotto gli occhi si è sviluppata l'idea
che l'impresa sia in contrasto con la
società che sia un soggetto che fa i
propri interessi a scapito di quelli
degli altri Quindi la società si debba
difendere e va già bene quando riesce a
evitare che l'impresa faccia danni con
la sua attività Ecco io non mi rassegno
a questo modo di vedere e vorrei che
nessuno si rassegnasse a questo
stereotipo dell'impresa nemica della
società
propongo il sostengo un modo di vedere
dialmente opposto secondo il quale il
bene dell'impresa il bene della società
non solo convivono bene ma si alimentano
positivamente uno con l'altro
come fondazione Buon lavoro sulla base
di questa idea abbiamo sviluppato il
modello della buona impresa abbiamo
anche realizzato degli strumenti
applicativi questa sera non posso
entrare nel dettaglio vi darò solo un
paio di idee molto Generali sperando di
incuriosirvi un po'
Prima di tutto però mi presento da dove
mi viene questa idea questo modo di
vedere viene da qui da 44 anni che ho
passato a gestire l'impresa di famiglia
qui alcuni dei collaboratori con il
quale ho lavorato alcuni dei prodotti ci
ho messo anche le mie foto da bambino
con i due nonni entrambi imprenditori di
prima generazione Questo per dire che ho
cominciato a respirare cultura d'impresa
molto prima dei 44 anni di lavoro nel
complesso una situazione particolarmente
un'esperienza particolarmente
fortunata al punto che ho subito quello
che Adriano Olivetti definiva il fascino
dell'impresa e valuterete poi voi se
quello che dico è da persona un po'
troppo affascinata o se c'è qualcosa che
può essere anche un pochino interessante
per fortunata che sia stata la mia
esperienza
di situazioni di contrasto in 44 anni
potete ben capire me ne sono capitate
diverse ma è stato proprio cercando di
affrontare quelle situazioni che mi sono
convinto dell'idea che Vi propongo e mi
sono anche convinto a raccontarvi una
storia di successo nella quale io i miei
interlocutori partiti piuttosto male
siamo riusciti a superare e a finire
direi in armonia
o anche diverse storie di insuccesso Ma
quelle le terrei per me
siamo qua sto parlando di una
cinquantina d'anni fa quando ho
cominciato a lavorare e nell'ambito
delle relazioni industriali il clima era
molto Teso tanto da cambiare la
declinazione del verbo lavorare io
lavoro Tu lavori e li lavora e si
sfruttano più o meno in questa
situazione
mi è capitato il primo incontro tra
l'azienda e il sindacato al quale ho
partecipato e la persona che era seduta
di fronte a me che faceva il
sindacalista non aveva niente che non
andasse però era completamente immerso
nello stereotipo del contrasto del tipo
tu sei un mio nemico non mi interessa
neanche sentire cosa hai da dire quando
ho cercato di intervenire mi ha subito
zittito così
Cito testuali parole zitto lei
sfruttatore
e
la riunione è finita lì non c'erano le
premesse però non c'erano in modo di
andare avanti Non credo che sia servito
al sindacato di sicuro non è servito
all'impresa è stato particolarmente
traumatico per me che mi ero presentato
con la migliore delle intenzioni
seconda parte della storia alcuni
decenni dopo la foto simbolo per me del
superamento
del contrasto è questa qui sono io
insieme ai membri del consiglio di
fabbrica quindi il sindacato interno che
ci apprestiamo andare a pulire i
giardini pubblici di Omegna Dove ha sede
la società
quell'anno non avevamo ordinativi
sufficienti per dare lavoro alle persone
invece di metterle in cassa integrazione
abbiamo deciso di chiedergli se volevano
andare a svolgere servizi sociali per il
Comune di Omegna che aveva avuto i fondi
tagliati dallo Stato
l'adesione richiesta su base volontaria
individuale Hanno aderito circa il 90%
delle persone alla fine tutti contenti
tutti motivati l'azienda ha avuto un
ritorno in termini appunto di
motivazione delle persone e anche di
reputazione ben superiore a quello che
aveva speso continuando a pagarli anche
se facevano un lavoro un po' diverso da
quello del solito più contento di tutti
io che le ho superato Finalmente il
trauma iniziale di cui di cui vi ho
parlato
però non è che l'abbia adesso non è
quello il momento non è quello il
progetto nel quale abbiamo
sviluppato la relazione la relazione la
buona relazione si è sviluppata in
decenni di lavoro insieme sul campo
prendendo le decisioni in un certo modo
adesso con voi non ho decenni di lavoro
sul campo per convincervi provo a darti
un proprio un paio di spunti
e il primo è una riflessione su quello
che fa l'impresa per la società E
partirei da qui
provate a pensare per cortesia alla
vostra giornata di oggi da quando vi
siete svegliati quando vi siete
preparati e tutto quello che avete fatto
fino a quando siete arrivati qui questa
sera quante volte Secondo voi vi è stata
utile l'impresa
Secondo me centinaia di volte nel mio
caso mi sono svegliato in un letto
prodotto da un'impresa in una casa
costruita da un'altra impresa lenzuola
comodino lampada lampadina corrente
elettrica Ahimè il cellulare i vestiti
la macchinetta del caffè prima di uscire
di casa avevo usato decine di prodotti e
servizi dell'impresa e poi ho continuato
così tutto il giorno senza i prodotti e
i servizi dell'impresa non mi saprei
nutrire non mi saprei proteggere non mi
saprei curare
in breve morirei nel giro di pochi
giorni
voi siete più giovani di me resistereste
di più ma qualche problema l'avreste
anche voi siamo tutti i clienti delle
imprese tutti i dipendenti dalle imprese
E questo dei prodotti non è l'unica cosa
che L'impresa fa per la società
L'impresa che è al lavoro
lavoro al di là dell'essere fonte di
remunerazione
è un importante strumento di
realizzazione per le persone il fatto
che si dica io sono un imprenditore lei
è una musicista lui è un manager
il fatto che si metta il mestiere che
facciamo attaccato al verbo essere la
dice lunga su quanto
il lavoro sia uno strumento di
costruzione della nostra identità Questo
è il secondo terza cosa da creare
ricchezza
e siamo tutti d'accordo che il PIL non è
la misura del benessere di una paese di
una società Ma quando succedono anni
come il 2020 il PIL crolla finisce di
essere la misura del malessere
Ecco queste tre cose questi tre pilastri
le chiamo io dell'impresa sono le cose
che mi fanno dire che la noi come
società abbiamo enorme bisogno
dell'impresa
anche se non sono l'unica cosa da tenere
in conto nella relazione provo a
riassumerla così il ruolo sociale
dell'impresa con questi due cerchi
concentrici al centro nel cerchio rosso
ci sono appunto prodotto loro profitto
ciò di cui ho parlato fino adesso che
sono la creazione di valore che
L'impresa fa per la società nel cerchio
più esterno grigio
si sono gli altri impatti che l'impresa
ha sulla società in particolare da
qualche anno si è troppo tardi ahimè
posta molta attenzione sulle tematiche
ambientali per fortuna adesso dobbiamo
cercare di
riparare al ritardo
sono molto d'accordo con questa con
questa attenzione credo che sia
imprescindibile per l'impresa
gestire e responsabilmente i danni che
potrebbe fare alla società ma non è
l'unica cosa che la società ha bisogno
dell'impresa
e poi abbiamo anche bisogno che lo
svolga bene quel ruolo lì quello rosso
perché come ho detto all'inizio abbiamo
sotto occhi esempi negativi troppi
esempi negativi e questo secondo punto
che vi Volevo sottoporre Quand'è che
un'impresa svolge bene il suo ruolo o lo
svolge male quando lo svolge in
contrasto appunto con la società e
quando lo svolge in armonia
Secondo me tutto parte dall'orientamento
di fondo dell'imprenditore da come
concepisce La relazione fra questi tre
elementi di cui ho parlato prodotto
lavoro profitto da come li collega fra
di loro dalle priorità che da che cosa
sta sopra cosa sta sotto questo è un po'
più complicato provo passo subito a
questa slide che rappresenta i due
estremi dell'interpretazione
a sinistra
tutto si giustifica nella misura in cui
realizza profitto così succede che
lavoro e il prodotto sono dei mezzi per
il fine che è il profitto
Questa è l'interpretazione né troppo
diffusa che alimenta lo stereotipo a
destra prodotto lavoro e profitto Sono
sullo stesso piano curarti con la stessa
attenzione
nessuno di loro prevalga sull'altro
ad esempio il profitto si qualifica
perché scaturisce dalle migliore
capacità di servire i bisogni del
cliente e viene reimpiegato per
migliorare la capacità complessiva
dell'impresa di lavorare bene quindi
fare buoni prodotti eccetera eccetera
forse si capisce anche un meglio questa
differenza se sostituisco a quei tre
pilastri i tre ruo che noi attori della
società civile svolgiamo in relazione
con l'impresa quei tre di cui ho parlato
prima
collaboratori clienti azionisti
investitori
a sinistra cosa succede che se
tra il lavoro e il profitto c'è una
relazione mezzo fine
finisce inevitabilmente che questo
cerchi di ribaltarsi nella relazione fra
le persone collaboratori e azionisti E
questo non può che dar luogo al
contrasto Ma di questa cosa qua non
vorrei parlare più a quello di destra
non è molto più bello il disegno di
destra
collaboratori clienti azionisti tutti
sullo stesso piano tutti curati con la
stessa attenzione nessuno Che prevarica
sull'altro
e non è solo migliore Dal mio punto di
vista
l'interpretazione di destra dal punto di
vista etico
funziona anche meglio sul lungo termine
nel caso di sinistra un cattivo
imprenditore nel breve potrebbe
sfruttare i collaboratori ingannare i
clienti potrebbe anche truffare i
piccoli azionisti e ottenere nel breve
risultati ma prima o poi usciranno a
ribellarsi
a destra sul lungo termine è una
soluzione Siccome è una soluzione che fa
bene all'impresa fa bene alle i suoi
interlocutori
da più garanzie di funzionamento nel
lungo termine Proviamo a vedere partendo
dal lavoro Se l'impresa riesce a mettere
le persone in condizione di lavorare
bene di esprimere i propri Talenti le
persone saranno contente Però anche
l'impresa sarà contenta perché lavorando
meglio faranno dei prodotti migliori a
quel punto saranno contenti in clienti
con i prodotti migliori comprando di più
compreranno ancora e renderanno contenti
Gli azionisti perché nascerà un migliore
profitto e se
questo migliore profitto verrà impiegato
per migliorare la capacità complessiva
dell'impresa
di fare di lavorare bene e quindi di
realizzare dei buoni prodotti si
innescherà un circolo virtuoso che fa il
bene dell'impresa bene della società
nello stesso momento
o anche una terza versione un po' per
ridere ma neanche tanto che è questa qua
perché il questi sono due tipi di
imprenditori si chiamano tutti
imprenditori però sono molto diversi fra
di loro a sinistra proprio con peperoni
che si tuffa nel suo deposito credo che
siano Doni non ha bisogno di commenti a
destra ho pensato di mettere Topolino
aspirante stregone quello del film
fantasia
perché è un po' maghi bisogna essere per
far funzionare un sistema così complesso
come è l'impresa un po' maghi Sì ma non
è utopia non è questa l'utopia a me come
ho detto è capitato di fare tanti errori
e quindi qualche volta non riuscire Ma
quando sono riuscito a farlo funzionare
è stato bellissimo per me e per credo di
poter dire per i miei interlocutori
forse un po' più utopia è il passaggio
dalla buona impresa questa
ha la Buona economia
provate a pensare se io e voi e tutti i
clienti dell'impresa ci rifiutassimo di
comprare i prodotti delle imprese non
buone e tutti noi investitori ci
rifiutassimo di investire in imprese non
buone e tutti noi lavoratori avendo
nell'alternativa ci rifiutassimo di
lavorare per imprese non buone le
imprese non buone scomparirebbero in un
momento e si realizzerebbe quella Buona
economia che penso tutti cerchiamo
veramente al servizio delle persone
e vi lascio con una citazione di Adriano
Olivetti in un discorso così non può
mancare il nome tutelare di tutti i
buoni imprenditori e ne ho scelta una
che mette insieme due concetti di questa
sera il coraggio di fare che è il titolo
della serata e l'utopia che è una cosa
di cui un po' ho parlato e che qualcuno
può aver vissuto come una cosa molto
lontana da sé Ecco Adriano la riavvicina
in questo modo
spesso il termine utopia e la maniera
più comoda per liquidare quello che non
si ha voglia capacità o coraggio di fare
buona serata
[Musica]